hello friends today i've got a little
gift from sony
this incredible pelican case there's
some little goodies inside but they've
also sent over a review unit of the new
sony a1 this is sony's
brand new flagship camera in an all new
category this is our first camera into
the introduction
of 8k sony mirrorless
hyped about this but i'm also really
excited about the
sony xperia pro phone they also
announced alongside of the a1
this is a very very expensive phone
we're talking twenty five
hundred dollars but this is something
that is geared towards professionals
towards creators
and this is not only a phone but it can
be used as a field monitor
also for incredibly fast transfer speeds
using 5g
so i can basically use this as a 4k
monitor
and i can even you know do a really high
quality 8k
live stream somewhere that supports 8k
live streaming
this is purely going to be just an
unboxing of the phone and the new a1 and
also the surprise
mystery pelican case that sony sent i
will be doing a follow-up review
covering some of the more in-depth
features on this and then i'm gonna be
going on a road trip and taking this
with me and i might
not come back again so i guess stay
tuned for that
i want to do this but i know you guys
probably want to see the a1 so let's
do this first my sister actually already
unboxed this and she re-box it for me to
unbox so if things look a little
scattered it's because they are
here it is oh this feels this feels a
little heavy
heavy boy definitely feels a little
heavier than the a7 s3 so obviously the
first thing that you're going to notice
about this camera and which is an
unfortunate reality that we are living
in right now
is that it does not have a flip out
screen which is one of my favorite
features in the a7 s3
but this camera is not really geared
towards vloggers
this is definitely a higher end camera
obviously i will
love to vlog in 8k and we have survived
many many years of the flip up screen so
if i do want to use this to vlog
i'm already a seasoned pro salesman has
a new faster refresh rate for the
viewfinder
there are so many new things about this
camera that i'm already
kind of overwhelmed
[Music]
i love that they have a new focus style
that will allow you to quickly change
between the various focus modes
we also have different shooting modes
here and of course we have all of our
pretty much standard controls over here
on the style so it does have a very
similar look to
most of the sony alpha cameras card
slots here we have two cf express
type a which are by far the best thing
that i have ever
experienced they are so incredibly fast
they did send this
with the kit but this does not come with
the actual camera
here's one of the cf express type a
cards i mean you're getting such
incredible fast write speeds
this one is 800 megabytes a second read
and write
700 megabytes a second and you do need
this to shoot some of the higher quality
contents
so you are still able to shoot on some
regular sd cards but honestly if
you're getting this camera i do
definitely recommend at least getting
one of these
they are very expensive but definitely
worth saving for
this is their cf express card reader as
well
and it doubles as an sd card reader
which is great because if you are
traveling with this you'll not only have
an sd card reader and you'll also have a
cf express type a and you're set to go
it's also heavy it's like this nice
like metallic feeling it's a it's nice i
love when things are unexpectedly heavy
let's check out this sony xperia pro i
honestly would love
to make a review video about this but
anything that i would make would not be
worthy because farook
one of my friends here on youtube his
channel's iphonedo has made such an
incredible video
that i i'm not gonna bother just go
watch his
he does some extensive coverage of this
it's incredible
i'm just gonna open it and test it out
do i have
a knife she does she does
honestly i feel like i'm kind of jaded
because i
have tested out so many smartphones over
the course of the years
obviously i love my iphone i love all
the new samsung devices there's so many
incredible phones out there but this
phone is really setting itself apart
when it comes to who they're targeting
because it is an expensive phone but
this can be
a 4k field monitor monitors who are able
to monitor all of your footage you're
able to control your camera
but it's great because a lot of the
field monitors right now like you it's
really hard to find
one that's that high quality and the
fact that this does have
5g you're able to get really fast data
transfer
so with this built-in hdmi port here at
the bottom
this phone has so many more use cases
than just a normal everyday average cell
phone this is a whole new
category oh we have headphones with
mind you my friends a headphone
jack and why this is kind of important
and very significant for this phone i
know most phones are removing headphone
jacks but you do want to be able to
monitor audio if you're out shooting in
the field
so being able to have that definitely an
added bonus so now that these are both
unboxed
i'm gonna set them up get everything
ready to start the actual review video
can't wait to try this out and again
this is something that is not geared
towards everyone so
when people are complaining on twitter
about how expensive the price is
that's because it's not geared towards
you i mean yes everybody would love to
have an ak camera but this is something
that is
geared towards higher end productions
because this is shooting an 8k
for me this is going to really add a
whole nother element
and up the quality of my 4k videos
because i don't really plan on posting
ak content here just yet i still will be
exporting in 4k
but since we are able to shoot at 8k
bringing that
down to 4k quality is going to increase
significantly
now i want to open up this sweet little
gift from sony
sony is such an incredible part they
have supported me and my sister in so
many of our fun endeavors so i always
love being able to get a chance to
view their products and their sweet
sweet surprises
what do we think is going to be in here
oh look at this a gift there's some
they've wrapped a gift for me
oh my goodness this is so sweet
this is for maddie this is for our dog
he has treats i love this it's grain
free all natural
he's actually with my sister right now
so he's not gonna get to enjoy these
just yet
oh a little tag with my name
on it look how cute that is
that's awesome all the little jackets
so i can stay warm look at me that's
going to be me that's going to be me
look at that look at this this is so
cute
a little sony alpha jacket let me take
out the gift
i'm so into pelican cases now they've
got this really cool
insert called a trek pack that you can
cut and customize and then
rearrange each one of the little
sections so that you can fit your gear
in
properly and you can change it up easily
so it's cool because you can buy those
inserts separately so i'm gonna have to
get one for this this is the
15 35 and this is the pelican air the
weight
between the pelican air and just like
the regular pelican cases
so significant i accidentally bought a
non-air i had to return it it was too
heavy i was like
you playing okay look at this jacket
it's got a nice little sony alpha logo
it's my size too ready for adventures
what's this to justine from sony team
that's me
something in here smells good smells
very good
oh it's from lush i love lush
i know this is a tech channel but nobody
can get behind a bath bomb oh yeah i was
like something smells good look at this
bath bomb and some shower jelly
yes please what a random little gift box
this is so cool
ocean salt i haven't been to lush in so
long i used to just go in there and
smell
all of their products but since coved
can't do that anymore
look at that oh look at this that does
it here for this quick little unboxing
so excited to get a chance to test this
out if there's anything you guys would
like to see me test
please leave it in the comments below as
we will be shooting that video
the next couple of days and then i'm off
on a covet safe adventure basically
just gonna drive around in
a vehicle and take cool pictures and
videos
so if you guys haven't subscribed to my
channel be sure to hit subscribe and if
you enjoyed this video hit like and
don't forget to hit the bell so you'll
be notified when i post new videos
i also have a podcast that i do with my
sister we're going to be podcasting
as we do our road trip so go check that
out it's youtube.com
samebrain and if you search same brain
wherever you listen to podcasts
it'll be there and if it's not let us
know so that we can be there
i'll see you in the next video bye
you